[Music]
so nice to have you back because it's
been a while and there's actually a
story behind this and i think we should
get into it
why don't you tell this tale well this
was
going back to the early days of our
career i guess uh i was a guest i was on
a couple times yeah and you booked me on
valentine's day which is cool it's
coming up yeah and i did love poems
right and i did a couple love poems on
the show and you may or may not remember
this and it went so well it went really
well that you're you came over during
the commercial and said you know uh our
next guest her pre-interview we're not
so sure she wasn't that interesting
she's kind of new can you have a couple
more poems so i sat here and i did a
couple more poems right
and uh well it almost ruined my career
as well yeah it almost killed both of us
because i had to bump the guess which we
never did we never bumped guests she had
a movie coming out called anaconda yeah
it looked terrible yeah
uh maybe you remember who it was yes it
was j.lo
i bumped j.lo this is like just a couple
years into the show this is like 1996 or
something i bumped jlo and i'm like oh
whatever oh my god
and then uh freak show backstage uh and
then it turns into this thing and then
she goes on to become the biggest star
uh in the world and i remember it i just
love i used to look at the footage over
and over again if you and i chatting
with me saying well i went along with
jeff ross so we don't have time for jlo
it was really fun you got stuck with
j-ro
me yeah exactly and our producer and it
was weird because it was her first talk
show and i just remember being you know
talking to you and andy and your crew
after the show hey great show and you
just saw this giant butt waddling down
the hallway in a huff
she was mad
uh all right well tell us what did you
do for the super bowl oh my god i got
invited to the worst super bowl party
ever
it's tomorrow
i don't want to go to them
kind of a dreary affair actually i went
to charlie sheen's house oh he had a
super bowl party
and i never saw him once
he was in it up in his bedroom the
entire party he was nowhere to be seen
so i was pissed i stole a football
it was a great game though a lot of ups
and downs
yeah and that's just uh beyonce's boobs
[Laughter]
you know beyonce is backstage i'm gonna
i'm gonna have to bump her i'm afraid
you go much longer thirty five hundred
dollars a ticket to actually go to the
game
at the superdome which is crazy because
just a few years ago you could float in
on a car door oh my god
too soon
that's what i do
too soon never too soon conan uh what
about uh grammys the grammys are sunday
thoughts about the grammys you excited i
love the grammys it's the it's the
greatest music event of the year unless
you've ever been to an actual concert by
anybody
all our questions will be answered on
sunday who will win who will lose who
will drown in a bathtub
wow what is bobby brown here lighting up
i'm a music fan this is my favorite show
of the year i can't wait to tell it's
your favorite ship it is
llc is hosting again yeah it's hard to
find a rapper who can pronounce gautier
[Applause]
everybody knows somebody like uh every
guy loves goatee they know somebody like
gotee because they're probably having
sex with his girlfriend
so are you going to go to the grammys or
no you would i'll probably watch those
at charlie sheen's house again yeah